a teenage girl who got shot in the leg
while doing her homework blasting new
york city mayor eric adams on rising
crime the 15 year old was sitting at her
dining room table when a trio of
suspects fired a barrage of bullets
outside of her home piercing her shin
after blasted through her front door she
said this about mayor adams quote it's
kind of crazy how he thinks just getting
homeless people off the subway will do
anything to help the crime rates it's
hard there's not much you can do to
effectively get rid of these problems
it's terrible that we can say that we
can expect it
that story comes amid other disturbing
examples of crime chilling video shows
the fatal knockout punch that led to a
61 year old man in new york dying five
days later police currently looking for
two suspects and another brutal video
from phoenix arizona shows a woman
attacked while working at a wireless
store that man arrested and she is
recovering from her injuries at home
well i'm going to come to you about this
we obviously talk about this issue a lot
and
the randomness of what's going on right
now
it feels insurmountable and that video
just showed of the the man who ended up
dying
that is awful you know it's pretty
randomness is something i think good to
focus on because what you're talking
about is the complete deterioration in
people's quality of life so it's not the
victims are not simply the people we see
on the video the victims are all of us
that walk around in fear of that
happening and it's not irrational fear
the one thing you cannot do is mess with
people's quality of life and what are
the issues that do that we just did one
of them we talked about economy all we
talked about during the commercial break
was gasoline prices and the price of
everything rising the five of us sat
here and continued the conversation
quality of life
crime you can't before i get trump kids
don't mess with people's kids you saw
that in loudoun county don't proselytize
racism or trans philosophy to kids
people don't want that and finally don't
make people fear for their life you need
evidence of it look at chesa boudin's
recall in san francisco even in san
francisco
as liberal as it gets 60 said i don't
want to walk around in fear in the
middle of a toilet which are my public
streets in an open-air drug market don't
mess with people's quality of life
judge on the chesa boudin front um it
sounds like we could get a recall in la
for gascon do you think that this is
something that we're going to start to
see across the country yeah i don't
think there's any question and and will
you put it very eloquently i mean the
truth is that people are fearful of
walking uh in especially in big cities
even if they don't think that they'll
get you know hit by someone
who knows what's going to happen if
there's a gun fight in your collateral
damage of someone else's fight but i
think that the chesapudian recall and i
think the future george gascon recall in
la is an indication that people are
paying attention because they're fearful
they're afraid and let's move it to
right where where you know this the
topic we're talking about eric adams
right now the mayor of new york city a
police captain who was elected because
everybody thought he would take care of
crime one other thing that the things
that he's really good at is is being
part of the nightlife in new york city
i've gone to several black tie things in
new york city everyone that i've gone to
he's been there all dappered up and all
ready to make a speech and say how great
new york is i don't want to see him in
another hot suit with another hot tie i
want to see him with his sleeves rolled
up i want to see him with a bunch of
cops around him not an entourage of high
pollutant people i want to see him go to
every crime scene and call out uh carl
heasty and andrea stewart cousins who
won't change the bail law in new york
and and uh governor hoco i want him with
a sign with all three every time there's
a crime mayor adams if you give a damn
about victims i don't want to hear you
talk start walking the walk
i'm with her she's got
wow yeah you brought up
you brought up the real housewives you
brought up the real housewives he was
over here rock center rubbing elbows
with two real housewives from new jersey
the least he could do is hang out with
some people who actually live here in
new york city i live not far from here
and speaking of not in not fighting
crime not enforcing the law there was a
there was a serial stabber
right down the street from here dozens
of bus was put released on bail twice
because uh alvin bragg's office didn't
file the indictments fast enough it's
happening over and over again right in
this area so these liberal leaders are
governing cities that where
hard-working tax paying citizens do not
want to live in a dangerous violent
filthy expensive hell hole whether it's
san francisco or here and the only way
this changes and i'll point to daniel
enriquez who is shot to death on a
subway train goldman sachs employee
michelle go
murdered deloitte employee is to have
these large corporations stand up and
say we are leaving your tax base is
disappearing and when money when the
money not only talks but walks
then they start doing something and stop
inviting mayor adams to all these
glittery
openings yeah sean final thoughts i
agree with will 76 percent of new
yorkers are in fear that they'll be a
victim of violent crime that's a real
problem in your city and if you don't
have safety you have nothing and so
liberals have taken on this new role
saying we want to reimagine everything
our genders our families but they're
reimagining law enforcement no cash bail
sentencing reform and we've seen the
consequences of reimagining law
enforcement it's been cataclysmic right
our cities aren't safe we're letting
violent criminals out of jail and not
holding them on bond and people get hurt
and the problem that i have with
liberals is if your policies don't work
change it joe biden change it gas scone
change your policies when you hurt
people but what's amazing is they sit
back and are are tied to the liberal
policy as opposed to doing what's best
for the people they were elected to
serve i don't get it as a conservative
boom hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else